prince hamza bin hussein is the former
crown prince of jordan
and a half brother to king abdullah on
saturday evening he was put under house
arrest
along with his family and members of
staff they are accused
of plotting a coup to overthrow the king
i should not leave my house
that i could only visit family that i
could not tweet
and that i could not communicate with
people
since then a number of the people i know
or my friends have been
arrested my
security has been removed
and the internet and phone lines have
been cut
this video was secretly released to
global media outlets
through prince hamza's lawyer i wanted
to make this recording
so it is clear to the world that what
you see in here in terms of the official
line
is not a reflection of the realities on
the ground
unfortunately this country has become
stymied in corruption
in nepotism and in misrule saudi arabia
iraq the u.s
and uk have come out in support of king
abdullah
jordan's foreign minister said that
foreign governments
might have been involved in the
attempted coup
the investigations monitored
interference and calls including calls
with foreign parties regarding the
suitable timing to start steps to shake
the security of our steady jordan
jordan has been a stable country in a
very unstable region
these events were unexpected and will
spook the west
which sees jordan as an important ally
in the middle east jordan is a very
strategic country in the region
it's one that has managed to stay stable
in a region that has seen quite a lot of
instability
over rece over the recent decade but
particularly the last few years
and i think that people are very
concerned about maintaining that sort of
stability
prince hamza was educated in england at
harrow school
and then sandhurst military academy he
was his father's favorite son
but when king hussein died hamza was
considered
too young and too inexperienced to take
over the throne
and so his brother abdullah was crowned
king
prince hamza is popular in jordan and
the very fact that the royal family has
publicly admitted his arrest
is an indication that things are more
serious
than they might seem on the surface
aleister bungle sky news